stéphanie fortin directrice principale
des affaires publiques et des relations
avec les communautés à gnl québec qu'on
soit madame forte bonsoir monsieur
fillion alors dites-nous pourquoi
berkshire hathaway warren buffett
choisissent finalement de ne peuvent
participer au financement du projet
comment comme jallet dit aujourd'hui
évidemment on peut pas confirmer
l'identité de cet investisseur là mais
les raisons qui ont été évoqués sont
celles dues au contexte politique
canadien que nous vivons à l'heure
actuelle ça veut dire quoi ça c'est quoi
le contexte politique canadien un
contexte est composé de plusieurs
éléments à il n'est pas à nous de
pointer du doigt un élément plus qu'un
autre mais le contexte actuel fait en
sorte que cet investisseur là-haut pris
la décision de ne pas aller de l'avant
avec l'investissement ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que ce n'était pas une
investisseurs qui faisaient partie de
l'équipe d'investisseurs que nous avons
donc nous avons 15 investisseurs depuis
le début du projet qui sont toujours
avec nous mais c'est sûr que c'est un
investisseur majeur et donc comme je les
entends dit dans le reportage chaleur il
va falloir réévaluer avoir moyen long
terme quels seront les impacts de cette
décision c'est majeur c'est si je me
trompe pas ces 4 milliards sur 14
milliards
en fait le projet d'énergie saguenay le
projet de complexe de liquéfaction ses 9
milliards et un cruel avec avec le gaz
odieux qu'on parle de 14 milliards ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'un projet
comme le nôtre ça fonctionne comme ça
dans tous les projets de gnl au monde
ça fonctionne par ronde de financement
donc c'est en investissant là nous avons
suivi à travers les rondes de
financement subséquentes faut savoir
aussi que la décision finale
d'investissement est attendu à 20 21
donc on a encore du temps devant nous
pour parler à d'autres investisseurs
potentiels et qui plus est il faut
passer aussi à travers toutes les étapes
parce que cette décision finale la cie
aussi sur le fait d'obtenir nos
autorisations que les projets
partenaires obtiennent aussi des
autorisations je pense entre autres à la
ligne hydro électrique parce que
n'oublions pas que notre projet se
démarque de par l'utilisation de l'eau
électricité mais pour ça faut construire
une ligne hydro électrique mais le
projet de gazoduc alors tout ça devrait
être considéré mais ces 4 milliards
en fait encore là on peut pas considérer
je peux pas vous confirmer les montants
mais ce que je peux dire c'est que
c'était des montants qui sont qu'ils
sont majeurs mais c'était pas un
investissement qui étaient là ok je
comprends mais c'est un financement
important qu'il n'est plus potentielle
en tout cas pour l'instant
pour l'instant quand on parle de
contexte politique canadien on pense aux
blocages ferroviaire qu'on a connu dans
les dernières semaines par exemple comme
je disais tout à l'heure quand ontex est
composé de plusieurs éléments moi je
suis pas là pour pointer du doigt
quelque chose par rapport à un autre
mais il est certain que ce que nous
vivons à l'heure actuelle crée de
l'incertitude chez les investisseurs
internationaux et on l'a vu pour
d'autres projets qui a eu des impacts
collector à la toussaint
et vous pensez aux blocages ferroviaire
qu'on a connu encore là on pense à
plusieurs éléments et une épée comme ça
c'est la joie était je veux c'est pas
une question de pointer une question
d'être clair donc blocage ferroviaire a
vu dans les dernières semaines
la tarification du carbone par exemple
ça c'est sûr que j'entendais tout à
l'heure dans le reportage que vous avez
présenté au niveau des marchés les
marchés et les prix sont au rendez-vous
à la situation laquelle on va assister
c'est qu'actuellement on est en période
de surplus de gaz naturel n'ont qu'à
partir de 20 22
ce sera la fin de ces surplus là alors
il y a deux fenêtres d'opportunités il
ya plusieurs projets en compétition dans
le monde des pages où ces projets
canadiens je pense entre autres au qatar
à l'australie mozambique qui se
développent également aux états unis
donc tous ces projets là sont en
développement la russie en arriver à
rentrer dans cette foule d'opportunités
là est assurément que le gaz naturel et
c'est ce que les spécialistes de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
vont jouer un rôle dans les années à
venir notamment de par l'augmentation de
la demande en énergie en inde et en asie
et par la fin des approvisionnements
locaux en europe quand on pense à la
fermeture du champ gazier dans les pays
bas par exemple alors il met un gros
investisseur d'aujourd'hui crois que
c'est trop risqué pour aller de l'avant
mais comme je vous l'expliquais tout à
l'heure c'est pas de questions marché
c'est une question de contexte
maintenant qu'est ce que l'avenir nous
réserve
je n'ai pas de boule de cristal
aujourd'hui pour vous dire c'est pas un
scénario qui est écrit d'avancé
vous savez que dans le développement de
ce genre de projet
les choses peuvent tourner très
rapidement alors pour nous on continue
puis ça change rien aux fondamentaux de
notre projet la bonne nouvelle si on
peut dire dans cette nouvelle là
aujourd'hui c'est qu'un investisseur
important majeur au cru en notre projet
l'utilisation de l'hydroélectricité une
empreinte environnementale moins élevé
que le projet similaire de par
l'utilisation de l'hydroélectricité la
carboneutralité alors pour nous les
fondamentaux restent inchangées et on
continue de travailler et à discuter
avec d'autres investisseurs potentiels
diriez vous que ça devient de plus en
plus difficile d'investir au canada
écoutez encore une fois c'est pas à moi
de me prononcer là dessus nous on
travaille un projet fois posé la
question aux spécialistes qu'elle sera
qu'est ce que l'avenir nous réserve à
cet égard l'homme actuellement le
contexte ne crée de l'incertitude
oui le contexte et ça vous me dites le
cortex et on définit pas ce que c est ce
que vous parlez à d'autres potentiels
investisseurs pour remplacer berkshire
hathaway ou ce gros investisseurs que
vous ne voulez pas nommé il ya
effectivement d'autres discussions qui
sont en cours avec d'autres
investisseurs potentiels avec le
gouvernement du québec le gouvernement
du canada
écoutez si legault si les gouvernements
décident d'investir il a devant leurs
prérogatives à titre d'investisseur
parce qu'ils croient que c'est un bon
projet maintenant c'est sûr que les
gouvernements peuvent jouer un rôle
important dans le développement les
projets pour le voit dans dans toutes
sortes d'autres sphères de l'économie
mais oui il ya des discussions avec
d'autres investisseurs potentiels privé
et on va travailler à voir comment que
les choses peuvent évoluer mais
effectivement cessé
c'est un gros morceau et donc les choses
devront être évoluer à moyen et long
terme et pour nous là c'est important de
passer à travers les étapes de
l'évaluation environnementale le 16 mars
prochain les audiences vont débuter ici
à saguenay donc c'est une étape cruciale
et qui est essentiel aussi à la
finalisation du du financement est il
clair et je termine là dessus pour vous
là que ce projet va voir le jour
j'ai pas de boule de cristal nous on y
croit nous on est on est ici 30 employés
à saguenay a travaillé fort pour
or que ce projet là se réalise pour le
développement de notre région pour le
développement du québec
on continue d'y croire on a un bon
projet entre les mains qui est différent
des autres qui a une valeur ajoutée sur
les marchés mondiaux qu'il faut faire
une différence donc bien on continue
pour travaille fort merci madame fortin
merci à vous merci bien